welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Star Wars Ahsoka went in
directions none of us expected and now
the Star Wars fandom is left as usual in
a state of Civil War like does Da Fon
need a writer's room or are his
disconnected bursts of nostalgia perfect
and exactly what our broken world needs
right now or really who has the claim to
ultimate quality in Star Wars is it
Andor or anything with the lightsaber in
it I think the responsible thing for a
Star Wars fan to do is to keep their ego
in check if that's at all possible and
new Rockstar is going to do something
that no other YouTubers in their right
mind would do and score our Theory
accuracy with a special Ahsoka edition
of what we got wrong joining me today
are The Shins to my Balin the Enoch to
my thraw the huangs to my Ahsoka it's
our Wookie leaks co-hosts mod Garrett
and Tommy be told yay I'll be the shin
any day woohoo I'm huyang I'm a real
bummer and not very helpful until really
in opportunely late moments uh also I
will not admit to any wrongdoing
everything I said was perfect this
season no notes for you Tommy no notes
for you mod this is really just like
notes for myself I just I said they were
all going to kiss and if I recall the
show ended on a spring break quadruple
kiss so let them smooch that's what I'm
always saying let them all smooch let
the zombies smooch we'll get there yeah
I just hope that one of those cets had
two people who were spooning head to toe
if you ever only see one casket it's
because I'm carrying you
[Music]
inside oh my God all right folks let's
face it you know we try to predict where
these series are going but we don't
always get it right so today we are
doing a rundown of some of our biggest
predictions as we were watching the
Ahsoka series week by week and finally
admit to what theories we were wrong
about because really anyone can spout
Theory after theory on the internet but
if you want to run Victory laps when
you're right you got to be willing to do
a couple push-ups when you're wrong so I
want to start with at early episodes of
Ahsoka one of our biggest mysteries that
the series presented us with who or what
was Maro so you know we went into a lot
of theories before the season I thought
it might have been the ex or I thought
it was like ahsoka's friend of me Baris
aie then everyone went crazy thinking it
was like a star killer or maybe Ezra or
Maul I was like no let's not go crazy
and then I presented an even crazier
theory that it was a shanian wolf Jedi
so I just wondered if maroque might have
been an Inquisitor controlled with a
cyborg attachment or perhaps if we're
sticking with the wolf theme Here a
shanian the wolf-like species that was
originally in the Cantina Bar in A New
Hope a Moro could be a former Jedi a
shabanian who survived Order 66 turned
Inquisitor assigned a bodyguard
Palpatine or one of Palpatine's clone
strand casts one of whom became Ray's
father remember that and that Maro in
the aftermath of Palpatine's death was
lost in looking for a new Mission yes I
love that I'm sorry I don't ever want
you to apologize for that because to me
that would have been the most satisfying
reveal of all time that would have been
awesome I will say though you had
evidence to back up some of these I mean
like Sam witw was cited as additional
voices and so bringing his character
into the Star Wars Universe asaro could
have made sense uh I really like the
Baris Baris oie one Barista Coffee as I
like to remember her name uh that would
have been really cool because it does
tied into clone wars and as Dave filon
demonstr ated throughout this season he
was bringing a lot of stuff from Clone
Wars into this and that would have been
another great way to tie it in but we're
researching who the stuntman is in the
suit and it's a man but does it does it
look like it's a woman's shape you know
we were digging deep for that one turns
out were it was just a gas fot yes so
much more than that mod it was like
night brother Mist think I mean look I
got to say this is one Theory I was glad
that I was wrong about because I I think
just having him just be an anonymous
night brother named Maro not Anonymous
but you know a night brother did set up
the the really cool zombie moment in the
finale episode I didn't need him to be
the star killer or Ezra or Maul or Baris
or a wolf Jedi yeah but how cool was
that that the entire internet was
scratching their head and theorizing
only for it to be completely sort of
like the most biggest anticlimax but it
taught us all to just maybe reel it in a
little yeah I agree I mean I I think
this was uh not to date myself although
I wish I could uh this was like the Al
Capone's vault of uh of uh of of reveals
because in the end it was just kind of
like well there's like like you said
Eric it's what kylo Ren tried to
Gaslight ran to believe it your parents
were no one they were it was nothing it
was not like he was just a normal or not
a normal he was just a a standard person
a standard night brother I want to know
who trained him to use the inquisitor's
lights sa though that's what I want to
know I want know how long did he make it
through the entire Fortress
inquisitorius like training process as a
a humanoid Mist shape yeah is what was
he before when they found him a question
certain there I mean there are more
questions and we could nerd out on it
because it is like he was presented in
the first few episodes as some sort of
humanoid right like I don't think anyone
had gaseous Cloud as what was going to
be revealed but uh you know what no one
had that on their but I think mod your
point is Right Turn dial it back a notch
you know like let's uh let's we don't
have to reach so far out but reaching
out far is fun speaking of far away
what's the next thing we got wrong oh
yeah uh we're going to look at what I
think was actually a really good mystery
to dig into nothing against maroque I
just think like we are learning about
how to watch these shows and there's
some theories and Mysteries that are
like more of the the unin the UN what's
it called the unintentional Theory the
unforced Errors By the writers of like
you remember the W division aerospace
engineer where it's like the writers are
like no that was just nothing you guys
turned it into something I think we did
that with Maro but this is a question
that the show presented the star map
creators who's who lives on peridia um
right out the gate uh I think mod we
were talking about kns of the Old
Republic and the roton which I think was
a good theory but it ended up being the
line of like abandoned Exile you know
what I mean like a lost a lost sort of
generation
but I am betting that the ancient people
from a distant Galaxy that Morgan refers
to are the rakatans so the rata aka the
builders were an ancient amphibious
humanoid species the race believed to
have invented hyperspace technology as a
for sensitive race the dark side
corrupted the rottins and turned them
into cruel Warriors who enslaved every
other species they came across forming
their infinite Empire the rottins
actually came up in the Knights of the
Old Republic game which also involves
star Maps such as this yes um and uh the
show did not like at least through the
dialogue really answer this question
other than just the night sisters like
the death and Mary came from this other
Galaxy but you know uh through the runes
uh and there was someone on Twitter who
like translated this uh I'm sorry if I'm
forgetting your name but I've shouted
you out in videos before who was able to
translate the runes and talked about
kuet which is a poll from Jedi Fallen
order um now I hope that that that did
not actually get specified in the
dialogue of the finale and who knows if
we hear Zeo spoken aloud outside of the
Jedi Fallen order Jedi Survivor games
ever in Star Wars live action um but it
I think that's enough of a pull for us
to say that like the zepo is who lived
here we just still have a lot of
questions of how tied end the zepo were
with the night sisters uh which cult um
and who predated whom there um but
either way it was not the rottin dead
wrong on that good so I guess that's
kind of something we do have to touch on
for every uh one of these we do if a
question is not firmly answered by a
series does that mean our theories were
wrong or just our theories weren't right
yet T if a theory is crafted in the
woods and not embraced by the creatives
of the series was it ever a theory at
all o oh we
are in the
wind you live your life like a night
brother
in we went two different wind songs but
that's I'm out of wind after that uh
I think we are all winners in the end
though yes lot of hot air for
sure uh we have to move on to a very
fluid dimension of the world Between
Worlds introduced halfway through this
season uh I think one thing that I have
to fess up on is what exactly Anakin was
what what Hayden Christensen was really
playing in the world Between Worlds I
think it's fair enough just to say he
was the Force ghost of anakan talking to
like my only Theory with it cuz you know
we've seen him as a falce ghost in the
trilogy already um we've seen two
versions the original Anakin and then
Hayden christenson's Anakin um and we
kind of have a lot of an understanding
of what F go are thanks to Quon Jin who
I think was the first person to kind of
establish what that was um we've never
really
had um iterations of like uh a
hallucination or anything outside of
Force ghost in the Star Wars Universe
have we it's communicating in the head
it's used the force Luke you know Ry
heard voices in the rise of Skywalker
and we don't know if that was just in
her head I think it was from outside
head yeah and kylo had a whole
conversation with Han Solo in uh in um
the rise of Skywalker that is presumably
was in his own head right like I I mean
it's debatable yeah cuz Han was not a
Jedi Han was not force sensitive so I
don't think he could be a force ghost um
a lot of stuff happens in the last or in
the rise of Skywalker that people don't
really have answers for yeah but you
know what we do know Anakin is back and
he's in POG
form hard win for Hayden Christenson to
fess up on some theories like when I
first saw Anakin my mind was jumping to
the son of the Gods of mortis um because
I first saw his lightsaber and I was
like I don't know if that's his
lightsaber or was just like the lighting
on it uh and then later I did a
follow-up video where I think I just was
wrong like I was like oh it's got to be
ahsoka's own subconscious and so this
projection of Anakin is really a fusion
of what Ahsoka has brought to the table
with her subconscious and the ghosts of
the past and of the future that are
already waiting for her there like I
couldn't just accept the reality that
would be Anakin's forc ghost because I
just felt like there was too much of
like ahsoka's own needs that were baked
into what this version of Anakin was
like he was like shifting between his
Vader self and his Anakin self based off
of like what Ahsoka needed to get
through it I think the biggest takeaway
is that the world Between Worlds is
really just what the Jedi who enters it
and what they see and what they need in
that particular moment of their life but
I think what Anakin was was the Force
ghost of himself I I I agree Eric and I
think that it it's kind of fascinating
if you think like because of Anakin's
dual uh experience with the force he can
shift as a force ghost into a light side
Force ghost and a dark side Force ghost
like he C he can present as a Sith Force
ghost then he can present as Anakin
Skywalker Jedi
uh Jedi Master i i i that obviously
hasn't been confirmed or anything but
like that's an interesting thing to play
around with with the Force ghost like
spectrum of like what their powers are
and what they can do like is there like
like is there a chance we could get uh
Count Dooku as a force ghost I actually
don't think it's a Sith power I think it
is exclusive to the force uh to the
Light Side um yeah it's because we've
never we've never seen a a Caporal or a
or a force ghost of Sith user I think
Anakin was able to flicker into Vader
momentarily because he does embody both
um and he is incredibly powerful so he
has trained in both the light side and
he fell to the dark but I think what
they were really trying to hone in here
is that Anakin died when Vader um was
sort of born I guess so they they don't
technically coexist it is one then the
other and that's why we keep getting
Anakin as the Force ghost because it
encompasses his light side I do want
though asked though what was the moment
in those interactions that solidified it
being a falce ghost because the one that
comes to mind for me was when Anakin
literally could not recall an event that
was taking place through ahok's memory
and that's because he literally wasn't
there he was already working with cidus
to become Vader and so he's like well I
wasn't here and she's like yeah this is
where I faced off with Maul like this is
like a huge part of my life and you'd
already left and so it's like Anakin can
only harness what he knows because it is
his Force ghost you're absolutely right
M and I and I saw that and I should have
just like left it at that because that's
simple enough I think that's why they
put that line in there is it was meant
to show that Anakin was not there for
that and he couldn't see it and that
ghosts can only retain the memories that
they had in their waking lives but I I
think there was just like the fact that
he did flicker into Vader for me was
like Ahsoka seeing him as Vader in that
moment like it was her own fear as like
the bad kind of mentor to Sabine that
like saw that mask over him and that he
as a force ghost was like helping do
that kind of Kabuki for her to like to
scare her not scare her out of it but
just to kind of show like hey these
fears you have are super ficial you know
like you can just defeat this Vader
version of me and you'll be good to go
be a good Mentor to sine but yeah
definitely hor ghost I had a theory
about the world Between Worlds which I
was incorrect with um especially in this
time of the show where Sabine has gone
off uh you know the ship has left and
the The Vessel that was able to do the
time Jump oh my gosh hyperspace um had
all gone so the way to get to peridia
all me like all means of Transport gone
and I actually thought the world Between
Worlds could act as a way to get from A
to B to get from where they were to
peridia through the world Between Worlds
I mean you even see it it's like Rainbow
Road on Mario Kart but if you just kept
walking down it you could pop out into a
different place and I also wondered if
maybe she would be meeting Ezra in there
since it was Ezra that kind of brought
awareness to the world Between Worlds in
the first place and I was wondering I'm
only thinking this really now but like
he was using the world Between Worlds as
sanctuary away from thrawn CU then he
couldn't he couldn't be touched because
thror wasn't a force user so I thought
that there would be a lot more between
uh with the world Between Worlds than we
saw than just sort of like a flashback
training moment for Ahsoka to turn into
Ahsoka the white really I think that's a
fair assumption to make M because like
in Rebels we do see like Ahsoka comes in
through a gate from malachor uh from
meets Ezra in the world Between Worlds
he came in from lothal so like it should
be able to be a Gateway point to kind of
jump through you know but I think filon
has been very cautious to use the world
Between Worlds for any kind of like
physical changes to time or to space I
think you mean as a plot
device he uses it just for kind of like
an emotional member berries Nostalgia
pool rather than like something that can
actually be used to like get characters
from A to B but like I honestly thought
it could have gone there too I I mean
going into the series I really thought
that's what they were going to use the
world between if they brought in the
world Between Worlds why not use it as a
as a way but I I think that's felon's uh
red line that he doesn't cross now I
figure you wouldn't be watching new
Rockstar videos if you weren't a fan of
Star Wars which would mean you know
other Star Wars fans if you're thinking
ahead to the holidays and wondering what
to get for the fan who has everything
check out this holiday themed 32 o grou
Tumblr from age of sage age of sage
makes highquality stainless steel Tumbl
cups ideal for everybody with a ton of
Unique Designs designed to make grou
your constant companion the mug is
insulated so it can handle hot or cold
drinks the lid is super convenient when
you're on the go and has a non-slit
bottom to keep from spilling also it's
made out of ultra durable stainless
steel so you don't have to worry about
it getting dented no matter where you
bring it order your 32 oz grou mug from
age of sage today by clicking the link
in the description below or find a mug
from one of your other favorite fandoms
like Mario Lord of the Rings or The Last
of Us in their store let's move on to
talk about this mystery of what Balin
was hearing a mystery that the show
still leaves us with but does leave us
with a big clue um when he mentioned
that to Shin my thinking was it was
going to be one of three options I said
it could be bendu it could be the gods
of mortis or it could be the Wellspring
priestesses maybe this great power is
bendu the forc being in Rebel season 3
that eluded Thon and predicted thon's
defeat at the arms of the pgle but the
second suspect are the mortis Gods whom
I've talked about a l a lot in recent
videos they come from the Clone War
season 3 Arc they're kind of the three
Gods the Holy Trinity of the Star Wars
Universe the daughter lives on in aoka
and I like the interpretation that the
father could live on in Anakin's ghost
so yes we should include the mortis Gods
as possible suspects I cited a really
fun Theory from den of nerds that uh
talked about abalo who was the mother to
the three gods of mortis um from from
Legends material and it ended up being
something related to the gods of mortis
right so we were right in that regard
but I I have to fess up I thought it was
going to be bendu of those three I was
definitely like it's most likely to be
bendu because I was like oh Tom Baker
voices him he's a former doctor and then
we have you know the voice of hang David
Tenant is is a doctor so it's just easy
enough just to do voice over and then a
pair of eyes and clouds and that's
enough but they they're going to gods of
mortis Arc we just don't know I mean we
had three statues of gods of mortis but
we don't know what that light is on the
Mountaintop in the distance and we also
don't know who represents the father son
and daughter yet we've got our theories
and we theorized heavily with who could
fit that mold um but still no answers so
that's a TBD as well and Eric I was
right there with you on bendu I was on a
bendo bender I believe that there could
be uh there could be a bendu like
creature on that planet but maybe like
the in the way that bendu ultimately was
like I'll help you like if you if you
need wisdom I'll teach you and like kind
of like gave warnings about the holocron
like ultimately seemed to be on the side
of good but was like I'm but I'm neutral
but but did things that leaned good I
thought for sure we were going to get a
a a beautiful cged uh bendu on peridia
and unfortunately uh in the end the
bendu was me the whole time I mean I
feel uh a bit mixed on this I I mean I
like seeing those statues of the Gods of
mortis but I kind of feel like even from
a writing standpoint I don't I don't
think it was Ray Stevenson's death that
caused this I just don't think that they
intended to answer this question so it's
kind of like well then whye the question
of like if you're not going to see him
like I just feel like the writing of
shin and balin's arcs was just kind of
incomplete from the agree also like
unless you are deep diving into the law
um to learn about the gods of morttis I
don't think that the average Star Wars
fan really knows all anything about that
so all they're just thing as a statue
that somewhat looked like Ray Stevenson
um and had really no understanding of
that particular moment so I for one I'm
glad that we are theorizing and bringing
this attention so we can learn a little
bit more about what is happening in the
law but yeah the fact that there are no
answers for that and raising more
questions than we have and even more
variables about the fact that Ray
Stevenson will not be back to be able to
sort of continue the the role of Balin
um yeah that's that's a really difficult
one for the Star Wars fans to be left in
the Lurch in that particular way I still
think that the father is Anakin because
he encompasses both the light and the
dark I think it's a totally good
interpretation of it yeah and I've got
good theories for that one Ahsoka is
probably the daughter and it's just a
question of who the sun is would the sun
be Shin I kind of like the idea of
linking Shin with the sun because that's
just where she ends up but Balin sent
her away if she was a part of that then
he would have been continuing his
apprenticeship with her the fact that he
was like this does not concern you I'm
going to do this on my own now does it
mean that he and is he an acolyte of the
Gods of mort we don't know we don't know
we don't know um I want to quickly fess
up I thought wolves were going to be way
more important on this show and that's
really just because Dave filon is a wolf
boy and we had wolf imagery on the star
map closing credits uh shin and hati are
named after the Wolves of nor smithology
I thought we were going to get more wolf
stuff maybe not loath wolves but just
like some kind of resolution of why they
were named wolf things but nope the
Wolves were just Vibes the Wolves were
just Vibes I actually thought they' be L
wolves because they were the um animals
that actually had access to the world
Between Worlds so the um Perles were the
ones that had access to sort of like the
hyper drive to get that far um but it
was a l wolf that could travel between
World Between Worlds so I thought that
there would be like some sort of spirit
guide or you know a bendu esque type
sort of entity to be able to act as that
and of course yeah it would have been a
wolf but we didn't get that at all did
we we got crocodile wolf dogs we got
Howers yes
Howers which I love those Howers looked
great CGI on those were was awesome I
loved him definitely some swings and
misses for our our predictions for the
finale um now I really thought for sure
we were going to get at least Zeb on
this show Ezra clarifies that Zeb is
training recruits and it's our first
mission of Zeb on this series finally we
have one more episode and we know
Lucasville made a liveaction Zeb for
that Cameo and the Mandalorian so if we
don't get a reunion between Zeb and Ezra
in this finale we're going to
Riot got Zeb Mandalorian got Zeb and
sooka about the original Rebels crew
with Zeb in it didn't get Zeb I I mean
Zeb I think we're fair to assume I I but
look I will say the days before the
finale I was hard predicting Kane and
jarus Freddy Prince Jr was going to show
up now show up how because he's like as
a force ghost or in a flashback sequence
as like a force ghost in kind of a world
Between Worlds with Ezra on the Chimera
and those loal ruins that are still on
the ship um or just his voice I mean
look Freddy Prince Jr has said several
times he's done he's done but um I just
thought if they could get Hayden to come
back if they could get Liam niss to come
back surely they could get Freddy Prince
Jr to come back he did have a line of
dialogue in the end of Rise of Skywalker
when all the force ghosts were like
having that moment so he had that but
you're right they I mean at least he got
a mention cuz it took about three or
four episodes for him to his name to be
said and I was worried that that was
just is going to be like dusted under
the the rug a little bit so at least he
got named he did he got a shout out but
man I was like he's going to have his
lightsaber he's going to hand I know I
wanted that too Eric I I after watching
Rebels I was like please come on show me
Kan and Jaron live action once just one
just a little bit that chin facial hair
yes yeah just a little yeah didn't e
build his lightsaber though cuz you know
how Kanan always had a much thinner
blade um
yes we kind of like emulated that in
honor yeah yeah I think so I think
that's as much as we were going to get
for him um any other General predictions
uh that we feel like we got wrong that
we want to fess up to from Ahsoka I
wanted Sabine and shin to kiss but maybe
I'll just keep that to myself okay all
right well there's just a lot of tension
between the two fighting the whole time
yes especially that episode one fight
there was something there yeah yeah we
should go some of the theories we got
right for Ahsoka um because Tommy I need
to give you a shout out you mentioned
that those night troopers were going to
turn into zombies and boy howdy dead
they that was such that was one of my
favorite moments of this season and uh I
believe you were totally right about
that one that's an army of the Dead
reanimated by the night sisters Tommy
that's a cool theory if you look back in
my illustrious time at this channel it's
not often that I'm correct so I will
hang I will wear this one like a crown
because most of the time in these videos
I'm just going and then I said this and
it was wrong and then I said this and it
was wrong and then I said this and this
was the one time that I was mostly kind
of right so thank you Pinnacle of your
career this is this is thank you this is
the peak of my career top of the
mountain for me night Troopers are
zombies I felt good about that you guys
got some stuff right too though come on
let's all brag together I I think like
the stuff I got right was just kind of
like after the fact me kind of making
connections and analyzing stuff that's
always been where I've been better
rather than trying to predict things
with theories and where it's going I I
like being more reflective after the
fact and just being like hey doesn't
this remind you of this other moment in
Star Wars or hey doesn't like the way
that like it's this is edited right now
kind of feel a
little or specific and there might be
some kind of emotional effect that
they're trying to convey by that that's
where I have more fun honestly um so if
I was mostly right it'd be that kind of
stuff like I think that was fun how I
feel that hey I got right I don't know
if this is true though you do hear a
light motif of the attack of the Clones
theme music um right in the moment that
you see uh Anakin's Force ghost in the
final shot that's that song is called
across the stars and I just thought it
was cool because this show has been the
Star Wars title to take us most across
the stars and you know Duel of the Fates
gets like all the credit from the
prequel I mean John Williams was like
suck and dingers I think in the prequels
not just with Duel of the Fates but like
across the stars is a beautiful
composition of music and I love that
they brought that in you know I called
the pgle migration pattern yes it's not
much but I just I had a David Aton for a
moment the burgles will go across the
Galaxy just to get to kidia and to die
oh uhoh one little Perle seems to have
lost his way if you're quoting the Blue
Planet one where the the migration
pattern of the whale and then the killer
whales took down the cough and only ate
its tongue and it sunk to the bottom of
the ocean I don't need to be reminded
about that right now the brutality of
the oceans is the only thing guaranteed
as the sun sets in the Pacific I don't
think I got anything else right you know
what I got right doing the show with you
guys H yeah 10 out of 10 that was
definitely 10 out of 10 I you know final
thoughts on this show I uh it was not my
favorite Star Wars title I think of the
mo of the recent filon ones I I think
Ahsoka did more things that I loved I
definitely preferred it to the
Mandalorian season 3 into the book of
Boba Fett but I think I really loved
Mandalorian season 1 and Mandalorian
season 2 better I think they were just
simpler they were more contained and
then Andor for me is at the top I know
there's a lot of debate over Andor
whatever but I just think Andor is in a
completely different class I it is but I
would say that Ahsoka captures the feel
of Star Wars more than Andor did but
that's CU I don't think Andor was
supposed to I think it was supposed to
feel very different
um and Star Wars you know intrinsically
to me is sort of Jedi and lightsabers
and all of that and so I think by I
think that really encapsulated sort of
like what star what Star Wars is uh and
it did a good job of that there was just
a little bit of pacing issues I think
just like the first few episodes were
slow and then it ramped it but I really
loved the finale and I thought it kicked
a home run with that one and I just I
and it's left me wanting more which I
think is a great thing for a series to
do agree yeah I just I don't want to say
that anything isn't Star Wars like I'm
just so tired of that argument online
like this doesn't feel like Star Wars
it's like no sometimes that's a
beautiful thing sometimes it's like it's
great to see just how far it can go and
to challenge new areas like I still
think that Ahsoka would have been great
if it had a little bit more of that
horror theme sort of drip through if
you're going to have zombie night
Troopers like let's and like you know
night sisters and witches it's like yeah
let's really build and it's like playing
up to October like it's all there for
the mem to kind of like really lean into
into that genre more because I think
we've got the foundation completely
sorted of what Star Wars is now we get
to explore different ways to tell the
story within different genres right we
did get to see uh for the first time
something I've I've long dreamed of
seeing a zombie get brained with the
ignition of a light saer oh that was
wonderful sabine's Redemption Sabine
summons the lightsaber and just it threw
the guy's head oh so satisfying I I
completely agree with you guys I
honestly think looking back they could
have saved thron for a season two like I
I love Lars mikkelson I love the
character of thraw but they didn't
really have anywhere for him to go in
these couple episodes that we saw him in
and I don't think he o he didn't get to
like take over the show the way that he
did Rebel season 3 and rebel season 4 so
I honestly think yeah this first season
could have just been like about ahsoka's
mentorship with Sabine her um
exploration of the world Between Worlds
the the whole mystical side of Star Wars
the the night sisters they could be the
villains the path to peridia I don't
think we need thraw yet I think thraw I
mean they made such a big promise with
Thon in the Mandalorian season 2 so
maybe they felt like they had to deliver
on it but then it should have just been
a thron show an Ahsoka versus Thon show
and that's it and we don't then we don't
have the whole nightsister magic I just
think what they pulled off more
effectively in the show was the
nightsister sorceries agree yeah I kind
of wish there was a little bit more Ezra
um outside of thn so it's like we got to
have that sort of reunion and to get
more of sort of the rebels Nostalgia fix
and to get more character development
there and then kind of bring thoron is
as a threat when things feel good
together um but you know speaking of
Ezra Eric you hit a home run with
something that you predicted about Ezra
didn't you I wouldn't call this a home
run maybe a base hit like I just you
know I think we all kind of expected
that Ezra would like sneak aboard the
chimer and put on stormtrooper armor at
some point but that's just something he
does in like 60% of the episodes of
rebels you know my hope is that they
just pull an Ezra favorite and disguise
himself with some of these dead night
trooper armor but you know you know what
Eric I have to say I felt like the
finale was really the only episode where
Ezra acted like Ezra like yes he finally
like kind of which I guess kind of makes
sense like if you've been like exiled to
this completely different galaxy like
you probably do lose a part of your
Social personality but he was messing
with with a Droid he was being kind of
quippy he was uh he was fun and then and
then he did his classic uh stowaway and
pretend to be a stormtrooper move so I
give yourself a double at least Eric
fair enough fair enough I'll get a
double yeah or I just got hit by the
ball I got walked
and you got bean and then so I got I was
someone else's RB you got you Gotan yeah
I think that sounds all right s bean oh
man uh look I had so much fun talking
about uh Ahsoka with you guys and I just
appreciate the two of you so much you're
you're both so insightful so nerdy so
hilarious and this is just great to be
able to watch my pleasure guys let's do
it again yeah let's do it again and
thank you to all of you for hanging out
with us these past uh several several
weeks and uh and I believe the next show
we're going to be looking at is probably
a Andor season two but you know we might
be getting some um some other stuff in
between maybe an acolyte trailer or a
skeleton crew trailer or drop we'll see
but we'll be here to talk about it um
and we'll leave it there if you haven't
already be sure to check out all of our
Ahsoka breakdowns on the Channel all of
our Ahsoka after shows on the breakroom
channel uh we broke down all the
episodes of rebels um and uh you can
support us by grabbing some merch over
at nerd r.sh follow me at eaos follow
Tommy at Tommy Beck told follow modmod
Garrett and uh check out all the new
rockstars channels for analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye everybody bye